Hey everyone here on the freaker
cap channel looking to get some tips
on how to make award winning JavaScript games. My
name is Andrew Cuba, and I'm a software developer
and course creator on YouTube as well as judge
for the 2021 gs 13 Games competition. For those
of you who have not come across the GS 13 Games
competition is the JavaScript coding competition
for html5 game developers running yearly since
2012. Each year a theme is given in 2021,
it was space and the fun lies in the fact that the
total file size limit of your game submissions has
to be under 13 KB as per the name. And just what
can you make with that in KB of JavaScript? Well,
just have a look at some of these awesome games.
In this video, we will be looking at the top
20 winners from the GS 13 Kagan competition, as
well as hearing from the game creators themselves
who will talk you through the game and provide
you with some of the game source code so that you
can have a look for yourself what it takes
to make each game. This video is great for
those new to JavaScript game development and those
wanting to get in on the next year's competition.
So I hope you enjoy it. Now let's get to it.
So the rules are simple, all your code and
game assets should be smaller than or equal
to 13 kilobytes, or to be exact 13,312 Bytes when
zipped. Your zip package should contain an index
html file and the top level folder structure
and when unzipped should work in the browser.
Next, you can't use any libraries, images or data
files hosted on server are services that provide
any type of data. So for example, Google Fonts
are not permitted. Analytics and other stack
loading scripts are also not allowed, or the game
as a to fit in the package size limit. However,
the iframe Babylon js and three Gs frameworks are
not counted towards that limit, but you can use
them only in the WebEx or category. And finally,
stick to the theme. This is very much recommended,
but also free to interpretation. There are
some pretty creative implementations of the
theme of space and this year's competition,
which I can't wait to share with you. Okay,
great. Now that we have the rules covered, let's
hear from the competition creator and Joe Mazal.
Hello there. My name is Andre Mazur, and I'm the
creator of the GST, think a Games competition.
If you don't know it's a JavaScript coding
competition for html5 game developers, where you
have a whole month to create a game within the 13
kilobytes limit. It runs yearly every August since
2012. So recently, we had our 10th edition already
receiving an incredible amount of really awesome
games submitted over the years, many developers
publish making of blog posts, and every single
game have its source code published on GitHub,
so there's plenty of opportunities to learn from
the best. And the top 20 winners from this edition
will be presented by developers themselves in this
very video, so make sure to check it out. Okay,
so let's do it. Let's start the game winner number
20. and work our way up to reveal the number
one winner of the GS 13k games 2021 competition.
In sport number 20, we have hit the space by
combat. If you want to learn how to make a
game with movements as smooth as butter, hit the
space is definitely worth a look. In this game,
you hold spacebar to accelerate your ship,
reaching checkpoints to advance while avoiding
hitting planets and going near black holes. What
is also great about this game is that you can see
the remaining fuel in the top left corner at all
times. As without any fuel you cannot accelerate
any further. The only thing that will replenish
your fuel are the different checkpoints you need
to hit. If we have a look at the code, we can see
how well structured the game is everything from
the graphics so the audio has been organized in
such a way that is readable to anyone wanting to
have a look. Now for those of you who have not had
a go at playing around with Web GL, Web GL enables
web content to use an API based on OpenGL ES 2.0
to perform 2d and 3d rendering and an HTML canvas
in browsers that support it without the use of
plugins. Web GL programs consists of control
code written in JavaScript and shader code, or
GLSL that is executed on a computer's graphic
processing unit. You can cipn instantiated here
and its methods being used throughout the project.
To be exact. This is web GL two. And if you want
to learn more about it and its fundamentals,
please go here. If you use the JavaScript
library three j s, this kind of code might
look familiar to you. That's because libraries
or frameworks such as three js and Babylon, J.
S, encapsulate web jails capabilities, making it
easier to build 3d applications and games of this
game, Judge Bjorn ritzville said catchy music,
I like this slingshot gravity and it feels just
about right in terms of difficulty. I wonder how
the game would play if it was possible to zoom out
and see the target planet before launching. And I
said that it was deceptively harder than it looks.
Maybe I'm just bad at the game though.
If you want to have a go yourself,
please check out the link for the game and
its source code in the description below.
At number 19, we have Galaxy raid by Josep Del
Rio. What was great about this game was the
fact that there were levels to be unlocked pretty
impressive for a game that is only 13 KB in size.
In this game, you fight your way
through six different missions,
collect fragments and upgrade your ship. On
desktop, the ship itself will follow your
cursor and a bomb will be launched on the click
of a button. The game also has a touch option in
which you can choose to move the ship with your
finger and tap with a second finger to launch a
bomb. Don't want to use either those perhaps you
want to use the keyboard option. Use the arrows or
W A S D on your keyboard to move and
the spacebar or enter to launch a bomb.
And even more impressively, there's also a
gamepad option which supports both analog
sticks and directional paths. Use a B X or Y
to learn to bond with this method. This game
really covered a lot for 13 KB and also managed to
make the web monetization part of the competition
by allowing coil members to customize the ship
color, claim 1000 fragments and unlock all
missions. I also enjoyed all the cutscenes if
we want to cheat, we can have a quick look at
the game code to have a read of all the texts
for those scenes. Clearly, a lot of thought has
gone into this game and I can't help but be super
impressed. And what do the experts have to say?
Nathan lie call this a nostalgic send up of games
like Gallagher. This game offers a healthy amount
of challenges and satisfying progression with
the upgrade system. All it really needs is some
music to make the action a little punchier, but
overall the game was great. The web monetization
features are excellent given the amount of
challenge present in this game. Normally,
I don't like being able to simply bypass gameplay,
but in this case, this allows less skilled players
to experience the entire game in some form. And
ever Mazal said everything is well marked. Both
subscribers and non subscribers can read right
away what a bonus is, you can clearly see when
options are available and when they are not. It's
nice that there are several bonuses the subscriber
can decide for himself which to choose. Bravo,
the perfect implementation of web monetization.
At sports number 18 We have the game
escape by the judo who go by the name of PA
school. Oh, hi, we didn't see you there.
I say fun with my dog. This is me hell.
And this is stash. And we're actually just
playing our trying to play trying to play our
game on Xbox here. The game is called Escape,
and it's our submission to this year's
J S K. There can get Gs 13k games.com
Alright, let's talk about escape.
What is escape? No. Escape is a short
story driven platformer. With puzzles,
what kind of puzzles so like environmental puzzles
like you what does that mean? Like you push stuff
you pull stuff, you jump over stuff jump into
cetera. So it's basically walking, jumping,
pushing, pulling. The the world that escape is set
in happens in near future where it's clear that
mankind has destroyed Earth and the only way to To
live is to escape Basically too late, or anything
else. So we know we've we screwed up, and we
need to find a new home. Right? But it's the
game is not about finding the home. It's not about
the destination, not about humans that escape.
It's about whatever we as mankind leave behind,
it's about the nature, it's about wildlife.
And in fact that you can play as, as a wild
animal, right? Yeah, you play as a fox that
tries to make it to the ark. Can we call it
an arc? I think it's an arc. Yeah, like, last
rockets that's supposed to leave Earth. And you're
not the only one escaping? Because like, all the
animals are escaping, everyone was fine. So we
tried to create the sense of urgency and danger.
Actually, to be honest, like, since this is all
finished, now, I think we can be frank. Like, I'm
not entirely sure we succeeded at conveying this
sense of urgency. Like, you can see other animals
escaped in the background, but I feel like, we
also wanted to make this pretty relaxed game,
show gameplay. So like, there is no rush.
Really. It's like Witcher three, where there
is no mechanic of Rush logic of rush in the game.
But the environments, kind of, you know, it's kind
of forcing you to do to proceed faster and faster,
because there's fire everywhere around you. Right?
Right. So it's our handler at site, the world
is burning. You better hurry up. Exactly.
And you have your cubs cubs. Yeah, just escape
in random directions at the very beginning of the
game, before you even gain control over the main
player. So right so so you start outs and like the
world is burning. You better find the the last
rocket leaving Earth soon. And on top of this,
you're your baby, your fox babies escaped, and you
have to rescue them. Maybe we can focus more on
the technicalities. Now? Yeah, yeah, of course. So
yeah, let's let's jump into it. I think one, one
thing that I would really like to talk about is,
is good luck is the the framework that we use to
build this game. In fact, good luck is a project
by Neha and myself that we started two years ago.
And it's the idea is that we wanted to create
this templates, or a set of good defaults
that we can use for our games, mostly
for our competition games, but not only.
And what I think stands out is that this is
not your typical library. You're not supposed
to install it, and then import from it. It's
in a way, like every game is its own engine.
The end, like, ever, but at the same
time, no, no game has it has the end.
Right, instead of including Good luck, like you
would include your typical game engine into your
project, you just clone the repository, or
like use the template ability of GitHub.
And you use our bootstrapping utility to create.
And you project out of one of the exam, and you
get a lot of codes already for free there. So
you know, if you're interested in 3d physics, or
rendering, of course, but
also some utility systems like
moving around or in touch inputs, like it's all
there, and so ready to be used? Well, maybe we
should talk a little bit more what you get, as
part of good luck. And to talk about it. I think
it's, it's a good idea to talk about ECS. Right.
Right. So every entity has has different behaviors
attributed to it, right? But But what's
interesting about the ECS architecture is that
the data for behaviors lives completely separate
from the logic of the behavior, right? And that's,
so there's a difference between components
and systems. And what I like what I like
about this architecture is that allows you to
compose different behaviors together to build
something smarter, right, something unexpected.
Yeah, maybe we can show an example of this.
I think what's interesting is that's like the,
for example, in this and this blueprint, or in
this object. Essentially blueprint is just a name
that we chose for functions that create objects.
The the movement functionality is given
by the move components. And in fact,
there are other objects in the game that also can
move. And the only thing we needed to do is added
this very same component to them. And then it
just works, right. So here we have is showing
the blueprint for a bird, which is just like a
decoration in the background. But it doesn't move
and it flies away into into the distance. And
you can see that it also has the Move component
by virtue of which it does the
moving. Then, like the Move component,
the only thing that defines is is how to move
and how fast to move, once some other logic
decides that the entity should move. So for
example, we have this other component called
control control always, which is just a super
simple if you think about the super simple
version of AI, which, like all it does, is moves
or tells the move system that this entity should
move forward, every frame forward move
in the direction defined by right? That's
right. And you can see like, we used lifespan
here as well, which means that you know, after 10
seconds, the bird probably flown into the distance
in the fog, so you can't see it anymore. And so
we just destroy the object. And it's no more.
So you can think of this like you, you compose
the behavior for an entity out of many different
components. And then you have a number of systems
that all work on different combinations of these
components. So this one is actually very simple.
It only works on the lifespan component. But
maybe if you show a different one, and shake
maybe, yeah, this one. Yeah, so shake
expects the entity to have a transform
and the shake components, right. So actually,
every entity in the entire game, as long as
it has these two components will go through the
system. And this is very powerful like you can,
you can move different things randomly.
That's what the system check system does,
depending on where you need it and how you need
it. So for example, when we implemented the
Meier fire, that's an A particle emitter that
just moves very quickly, every frame randomly
and produces this erratic effect, it looks like
the fire is burning in a wide volume of space.
All of this is just implemented using a simple
for loop. And it's, I think, I love that. And
I still love that good luck is so simple, like,
that's the entire logic of the game really, is
that you have a couple of functions, a number of
functions. And all they do is just pretty stupidly
iterate over everything in the world and see, do
I need to check this? Do I need to check this?
Do I need to check this and you can do this 1000s
of times per frame. And it's crazy how performant
modern browsers and modern computers are like,
I think when we profile this, like the entire
update part of the game takes two or three
milliseconds it's it's it's nuts. Right? So
this is how were we where every systems system is
being called and every single one of those iterate
over every entity inside the game and I think last
like concert we we had like 4000 entities in the
game. So like this is doing probably 20 or 25
iterations over all 10 for 1000s of entities and
again, it's it takes almost no time at all, which
maybe is a little bit counterintuitive. You know
like I just loved it when we first discovered
that the good old fourth loop is actually the
most performant way of doing let's jump into
to how we build the world of escape. Right so
we used blender to build our props.
And apart from the farm level
we every every prop is built from two
primitives I believe. So we use the cube
most of parts of this barns cube and we used
cylinder cylinder. So as you can see here,
those are just batch of cubes we have a cylinder
inside. So actually like a single barn What is
it like 15 different entities, each one rendering
a cube or cylinder and they're all put together,
you know, in the right place on the right angle
to give the final result result of the bar and.
Right. And we did the same for maps.
So every element here in the
map is, has a name of Prop.
Like we have a booth property, we have
a box property barn that I showed you
earlier. And there's just cubes here in this file,
right? But were there just user cylinders here,
because of the I don't know what it was in this
year. And when we export the file like that,
city, okay. It's the the logic here is the
same as it was in exporting props, like every
this is ground. So for instance, we have a fence
instance that's located in some place of, of the
world, and it's rotated and scaled, according to
how it is in bed. How we set it up in Blender.
Right? Yeah, I think that's, that's all I wanted
to say about escape. But be sure to you know,
play it if you thought this was interesting. And
whenever you feel like learning about Game Dev or
making your own game, give good luck a try. Yeah,
consider it as your next J certain K. Talent
tool. tool of choice. All right, thanks. Thanks.
Spot 17 We have the game gamut shift by one grumpy
dude. The first thing that is hard to miss about
this game was the cool transitions and wonderful
3d graphics. Once again, thanks to Web GL to. This
game asks you to push stuff around essentially
unlock passageways, and reach exit portals. We use
the W A S, D keys or arrow keys to move around and
the spacebar to undo last push actions, as well
as are to restart the current level. Levels are
made by creating arrays of symbols or text that
symbolizes a game piece. Similar to the approach
or newer game libraries such as kaboom J S,
you can view some of the levels in this
level js file. I like this approach as it
makes it easy for us as game developers
to visualize what we are working with.
Judge crystal chi Tila said phenomenal. When I saw
loud audio head warning I knew already this game
was going to be polished and thoughtful. Thank
you for that. Then was the amazing music faded in
and these spectacular transition shaders showed
me the world full of awesome detail graphics. My
jaw hit the floor we could work the shines the
shadows, the reflections, the warp lens effects
on completing a level beautiful the gameplay.
Well, it's a nice Sokoban game very familiar,
but the puzzles were great and difficulty
progression was comfy and welcome amazing work.
At sports 16 We have adventure
in ASC to space by Nicholas loss.
Hello, my name is Nicholas. I have a
confession to make. I'm a game dev addict
for years for 10k. This year,
I submitted free entries.
And they all ended up in top 50. In this
video, I want to talk about two of these games.
So the first game I want to talk about
is adventure in ASCII space, which was
my main entry this year. As a kid I played
games like I owe ArmaLite on my Commodore 64
We traveled to space with your ship and shutting
down enemies watching out from bullets. And I
wanted to make that kind of game this
year. So I was very happy when I saw space
was actually a theme. So here's the intro text.
Most people skip this. If you didn't skip it,
you got some instructions and you
also get an achievement in iOS 13k.
So here is my sheep coming to ask us base,
chopping down enemies, collecting resources.
It is resources. I have an upgrade panel.
I can upgrade tree you need to pick
to pick things in the right order or select which
one you want to have first Which tree to select
If this will increase the laser speed
then it became quite boring. I mean, just these
random formations. So I started to add in levels.
One more upgrade levels, then you couldn't lose.
Then I added in checkpoints. And this was a bit
problematic, because I couldn't have automatic
checkpoints, but then you might lose some of these
materials, like I did here. The problem was that
some people that didn't read instructional thought
that C came towards me it was
actually an enemy and avoided them.
So yeah, I'm not going to show the whole the whole
level. But this is the start and start level.
As you could see, the game is ASCII based.
So I didn't draw any graphic at all. I had
that issue last year. And the texture bit too big,
took up too much space and had to remove gameplay
from from the game. So I was thinking, Oh, maybe I
will just do an ASCII graphic. And ASCII is built
into a web browsers because that's just a font.
So you can see here, I'm actually just creating
canvas, where I'm filling with text. So this
is the character, this is actually the ship.
I'm a few character hills that I'm using later
on as sprites. To pieces actually, the heart,
there's an ASCII code for that. So you can
get a heart for displaying their health.
Also, I'm using some tricks for generating
melt fake light. And for that I need
circle. So I'm actually adding a circle here
as well. I'm using later to create fake light.
One issue I had with this technique, most
that is font, it's a little bit different
in different web browsers. I mean, that's okay.
They look a bit different, but actually positions
differs a little bit as well. And not even in web
browsers on the same operating system. Actually,
it was the differ on different windows 10
versions. So I had to add a bit a bit of
padding around each character, which ended up as a
sprite in the end. But in and I think it worked. I
tested on a bunch of different operating system
and browsers, and I didn't see anyone complain
about it. Everything is Vm GL. I'm using this tiny
sprite module that I found on the Yes 14k resource
page. So I didn't have to do it every web GL
stuff myself needs time. So why do I need them GL?
Well, as you can see, there's a lot of
things going on particles and bullets. And
doing that without Web GL would have caused
the game to be where we were very low FPS.
One last thing I want to show before moving on to
next game is the level. So to generate the level,
I actually drew it here in GIMP. And this is
actually the level as a PNG file where you
can see the level structure to different entities.
Also decorations, everything has different colors.
In the end, the PNG file is a bit too big
actually. So I needed a way to compress it
even further. And I wrote a level compiler. This
is actually something I did for my game last
year. So I'm been reusing my own code. So I'm
going to the image data and looking at our Gb
colors. When they match. I'm adding a character to
a text file. And under do that for every color in
in a PNG file. And that will
end up as a text file like this.
This is much better, this can be compressed a lot.
And then in the game, I'm reading this text file,
clicking the level character here, I'm adding
tiles, or adding formations or whatever I want.
So that's a very silly way to make a level.
And then I was basically done with the game.
And I had almost three weeks left. So I started
to play around with another game called running
out of space. I didn't mean to submit it,
but in the hamlet became quite okay in game.
But it's actually not one I'm going to talk
about now. It's this one, space block invaders.
And I didn't mean to make a game of it. Actually,
in the beginning, I just wanted to see how much of
a Minecraft clone could be done in 13 kilobytes.
So what you see here is basically, the first day
I was having blocks added and created, I had
noticed functions to create very simple landscape.
I didn't have any collisions at all here. So
I'm just playing around in a very limited area.
Then I was working on the code a bit more, I was
adding collisions, and I thought that will be
very difficult. But in the end, it
turned out fairly easy to do. And I
had to collision Stanley in like 30 minutes
or so you're seeing a be collisions. So here
we can see that I can walk around, I can
actually place blocks and remove blocks.
And the following day, I added trees microf has
a lot of trees. So I was adding increase as well.
And as you can see there is some very
basic gear shadows underneath the trees.
So that's a kind of emulated sunlight.
And I worked almost two days on
implementing ambient occlusion.
So as you can see here, the shadows under
the trees is much, much more smooth.
And abundantly issues getting this
technique, right. And there's actually some
bikes still in it. But it's not very visible.
This gives the very smooth, smooth shadows
this was just three days before deadline.
And I actually got a whole day on my own
push I didn't plan and I couldn't resist, I
added some very simple gameplay to this world. So
maybe just the spacing wader character you have to
run around shoot them before this they destroyed
world is actually not real fun gameplay. There's
no go love the game. This was what I had time to
hand in one day. So what did I do to make the game
run fast in a web browser? Well, first of all,
I'm using Web GL. This would have been impossible
to do without Web DM. actually reusing code again
from my entry last year, when I had some basic
mesh generation. So this is normal mgL stuff.
I have a mesh builder. So I don't have
to fiddle with vertices in other classes.
So I can just say, add the left side and
right side to the mesh with the right UV
values, colors and other light values.
Then I think that's all the properties.
So the world is basically an empty shell, you
only want to render what's visible to the player.
So if you have two blocks on top of each other, we
don't want to render the top of the bottom block,
we don't want to render the bottom of the upper
block, if that makes sense, because that would
never be visible. So when I'm building the mesh,
I'm actually checking here, if the book at
the top, if that's not existing, then add
the top side. And then we do that for all
all the sides of the block. And that makes
a huge difference. If we had didn't have this
coded, game wouldn't be aware of it, whereas,
and this is the texture atlas I'm using. So this
is all the textures in the game. But because
it's repeating all over, in a 3d world,
it looks like much more. And I'm also
tinting and using different tricks to
reuse the same texture in various ways.
After the competition, I continued to work on
this for about a week, adding in basically endless
terrain rendering until the browser
runs out of memory. I add basic crafting
and the UI for that and different type of tools.
I also added a sheep that walks around very stupid
AI. But yeah, gives bit life to the world. I add
water, that's just an illusion looks like water,
but when you can go through it, but it can
can swim. Then I start to do adding in caves.
And I didn't get the result I wanted from the
caves. And somewhere around that point
actually start to stop working on this.
But a might reuse the engine or parts of the
engine next year. For a certain game, who knows.
So that's all I have to show. Well, I could
actually talk about this for hours. But I have
to keep this short. The music ever heard in the
background is my own. There's links here showing
my two albums and Spotify. I have a blog.
That's very inactive. I have Twitter.
Just ping me if you want to talk about
something. And see you next year in JS 14k.
Plus 15, we have Q one case three by photos
lab. Hi, my name is Dominic and this is my
j is studying country for 2021. I'm not really
sure how to pronounce it. So let's just call it
quick. This game was done as a tribute to the
original quake from 1996. And it doesn't really
match the competition's theme. But I really
really wanted to do this. So here we are.
Quick features two levels, five types of enemies,
three different weapons 30 Different textures.
Robots collision detection, not so smart, but
not completely dumb AI, some nice ambient music
and spatial audio. I want to go into some more
detail about how all the data fits into the game,
how the textures levels and models are stored.
Let's start with the levels. I had some experience
with building levels or maps as we call
them for Quake three. Since I was aiming to
reproduce parts of Quake one, I thought using
a map editor for Quake would be a good fit.
Back in the day, we used a tool called
radiant and while it wasn't really bad,
in hindsight, it feels a bit clunky. So this
is trench prune. It's a map editor for various
Quake engine games made by Kristian daska.
And I can't say enough nice words about it.
It's really really good. It's completely
free and open source so go check it out.
While quake maps allow for all kinds of funky
geometry I limited myself to only use axis
aligned blocks. These blocks can be quite small to
allow for stair steps or some details on the maps,
but they can also be huge. One block can cover
the floor or the ceiling of multiple rooms.
I was able to capture most of the famous e one
m one map from quake one the slip gate complex,
with just about 200 of these
blocks. I have to admit, though,
that the original map comes with a lot of
secret passages and rooms that I wasn't
able to fit in. So these 200 blocks can be stored
in a binary file with just seven bytes each
one byte for the xy and z coordinates of the block
and one byte for the width, length and height,
and another byte for the texture index. These
binary files with all the blocks are loaded in
JavaScript into a big array buffer and all the
vertices for Web GL are constructed from it.
The entities so all the things that are in
the map, the light sources, the enemy's ammo,
and health boxes, and so on. Start with
one byte each for the type ID, three bytes
for the position and two extra bytes for some
extra attributes. For instance, for the light
source as one of these extra bytes is used for the
brightness, and one is used for the color value.
So with all this, in the end, I
managed to squeeze in two maps,
using up a whopping 3.2 kilobytes in the zipped
file. The models for the game again, I'll start
in the simplest way possible, it's just a set
of three byte coordinates defining the vertices,
and then a list of indices where each three
indices define one triangle or phase of the model.
For the animated models, the list of vertices,
it's just repeated for each animation frame, I was
able to get away with very few animation frames
by just linearly interpolating between them.
I was using Winx 3d to create those models,
I exported them as a wavefront object file
and converted them into a binary file with a
PHP script. It's not really a good workflow,
and I really should learn a bit of blender. Next
up textures. This was probably the best idea for
this game. Instead of creating a textures as
PNG files and just saving them in the zip.
The textures are created on the fly as canvas
elements when you first load up the game.
This idea is nothing new. The demo scene has
done it since forever, but I falsely assumed
that you needed some complex operations to
achieve good results with generated textures.
Nevertheless, I tinkered a bit with the idea
and after some promising first results with
drawing random stuff on canvas elements. I built
a really simple editor to create those textures.
And I mean, really, really simple. This editor
just supports five different operations,
you can draw a rectangle, you
can draw a grid of rectangles,
you can draw some random noise,
draw text, or draw previous texture.
In the end, I was quite surprised myself,
with the results you can get with this,
it was really unexpected, also turned out
to be a lot of fun to build those textures.
The result of all this is a JSON
array that defines those textures,
all 30 of them, and a tiny library that reads
this array and spits out canvas elements. The
whole thing is on GitHub, it's called Tiny
texture tumbler if you want to check it out.
I won't go into detail of how the music is
stored. But the short version is that it's
similar to the textures. It's just a JSON array
of nodes that gets rendered into an audio buffer.
So with all the data out of the way, I had about
5.9 kilobytes left for the code, I want to show
just two things in the code in particular, and one
of those things is the render. I'm using Web GL to
draw everything onto the screen. And everything in
through in the game world is spit out to the GPU
for each frame. There is no occlusion culling,
or fancy math to figure out the visibility,
and doesn't really matter computers are fast.
The renderer uses only one shader program for
everything. So all the enemies and the whole game
world are drawn with the same shader. The vertex
shader handles the view rotation, the direction
you're looking at. The view position the object
position, the objects rotation, and planning
between two animation frames for an object.
Of course, it's inefficient to draw the static
wall geometry shader that can plant animation
frames and rotate geometry. But again, it
doesn't really matter. Computers are fast.
The fragment shader applies a uniform array
of light coordinates and light colors to
every pixel and does little else dances in
a loop one iteration for each light source.
So the number of lights in the game is fixed to
32. And to stay within this limits, the lights
are faded out after a certain distance. You can
see this fade out in a few parts of the game but
Honestly, I think it looks cool and adds to
the atmosphere. It's a feature, not a bug.
Completely unrelated to rendering. Here's the
collision detection routine that is executed for
each entity for each frame. This is very similar
to what I was doing in my previous game and Iran.
But this time, I'm doing it in three dimensions
instead of two. But the idea is the same. First,
you remember the current known good position of an
entity, you advance this position according to the
entities velocity. And you test if the final
exposition of this entity with the old y
and old Z position collides? If yes, you roll
back the final x position to the old position.
And then you do the same thing for the y and
z coordinates. Checking each of the three
axes individually, instead of just doing one test
with the final position allows you to slide along
the floor and walls and turned out to be really
robust. The real code that is used in the game,
there's a bit more stuff in particular checks
if we can step up a staircase, or if an entity
needs to bounce it off from the ground. This
is used for the bouncy credits, for instance,
but the gist is the same. It's just a
bunch of simple checks, no complex mess.
There's one last thing I want to
get into and that's keyboard input.
If you do ws D movement in your game, I urge
you to use the keyboard events code property.
This property is keyboard layout agnostic,
which means ws D works on French keyboards,
and CNY keys are not switched on German
keyboards. The current property basically
reports the key based on the US keyboard layout.
So you're defining your keys by the position on
the keyboard, no matter what layout is
actually used in the end, so the user's
local keyboard layout is completely ignored,
which is exactly what you want for your games.
That's about it. If you're interested in some more
detail about the game I wrote a making off post
on my blog fireballs lab.org. Thanks
for watching and see you next year.
At sport 14 We had the game
celestial Lighthouse by Tom Herman's.
Hi, I'm Tom for instant games last year, I made
a game called actual fonts. This year I made this
little lighthouse which is a physics puzzle game
about placing blocks in the atmosphere of planets
Avada thing will fall into the Klout score.
So to achieve this circular gravity I adapted
the physics library MatSan as and their attract
plugin. So today I'd like to demonstrate the level
formance since agile fine was a grid based game,
the love performance is quite straightforward
there. So lesson Lighthouse also required it
since generating all the physic shapes manually,
which require a lot of codes. And here's the
key, you should usually try to record data in
as little space as possible, preferably building
in hearts assumptions that reduce file size,
where possible. This is why for example actually
sensagent up as an array instead of objects with
more readable properties property names. So in
celestial lighthouse, each level has a lava core
and an atmosphere. So since this is a continental
level defined, we just define its size here.
And the level generation codes just takes care of
building the actual shapes of based on the inputs.
Furthermore, we define which shapes can appear as
random to be placed by a player. So simple shapes
as defined here can be a square and rectangle
or trapezium. This is then used by the game as
a grab bag of sorts. to randomly select the blocks
place once you place a certain number of blocks,
solve in this case you when the left
finally levels have a solid bad forms.
Those are these black shapes and the level. These
can only be regular polygons like like triangles,
squares, and even circles. You've got also
good shape in the hall. by making them negative
and if you require, you can also
change the size, the Starting Angle,
the scale. And you can even sense it rotation
speeds. And yeah, that's pretty much it, I
really enjoyed the staff performance because it
makes iterating on the level design properties. So
my main takeaway here is to make
it easy as possible for yourself
to test and improve your game and the levels
and it's alright, why and thanks for watching.
At number 13, we have Space Jam by Mark Roquette.
Hey, folks, I'm Mark rosette. I'm a developer
and musician currently based in Austin, Texas.
And today, we're going to be talking a bit about
my GS 13k entry called Space Jam actually got
the idea for Space Jam from playing farming
games like Stardew Valley, I began to wonder if
it was possible to make a game where you build
up a settlement using musical instruments as
the building blocks for the game. In Space Jam,
the gameplay is pretty simple. We start off with
two instruments and this oscillator. Basically,
the way it works is you can add new instruments
to the board using the notes that you collects
when the oscillator strikes an instrument.
This way you can build up patterns, beats and
ultimately earn more notes to unlock
more instruments. You build additional
oscillators to kind of expand your repertoire
and place them in different areas of the map.
So next up, I thought I would talk about
the spatial audio in Space Jam. Basically,
the way this works at a high level as you have
this map, and you've got a grid, and the cameras
kind of centered in the middle of the map,
and there's instruments that you can place
and they're going to be some distance from
the camera. And that's kind of where your
center is as the player. And so as these move,
you know, from left to right, or up and down,
I wanted to make sure that I was taking
into account their position relative
to this point, and controlling the audio effects
accordingly. So the first thing that's going to
happen is they're going to pan left or right. So
this is going to pan slightly to the right, this
is going to pin a little bit more to the left. And
if an instrument is all the way at the bounds of
your viewport, it's going to be panning fully in
that direction. So panning is the first thing to
come into play. And then the second thing is just
going to be based on the absolute distance from
the center, that's going to affect the amount
of reverb that's applied to that sound.
And also just the overall volume of that sound.
So what that looks like in code, have basically
consolidated all this to this function. And
update spatial effects is something that happens
up here in this move camera function. So yeah,
basically, anytime the camera moves relative
to the instruments, you need to update their
effects. And so this has got a bunch of other
stuff going on. But again, we're just
gonna hone in on this function here. So
this actually takes the instrument
that was affected by this camera move.
And then first, it calculates the pan values. So
pan x is going to be the instruments, position
in the extraction and the delta of that with
the cameras position and extraction. So again,
just you know, these types of values are here
that's in relation to the viewport itself. And
you clamp this here, I just have like a utility
function that clamps if you don't know about that,
look into it. It's super useful for just any type
of kind of quantitative coding, but especially
creative stuff like games. So basically, what this
is saying is the pan X is never going to be less
than negative one or greater than one. Same exact
thing with the pan y just in the y direction.
The radius this is just a simple
calculation to agree in theorem right here.
And again, the radius is important
because it controls the volume.
In a number 12 We have fast
contact by marketers silk
off. Hey people, Marco silk of here. I'm
a security enthusiast from Israel. It's
Amber silk on GitHub and Twitter and Gmail, what
have you. And I'm working for this magnificent
little company called noname. Security, we do
defensive cyber security for protecting API's.
The game I want to talk about today, first
contract was written for the GS 13 compiler
in 2021. It's a simple clicker game. And I have
footage of it here. So yeah, the usual staples of
the genre, I'll present its instant gratification
base, and the game practically plays itself,
it's not skill based. What I attempted to
do with this formula was a little story,
some of the things just happened and you have no
control over them. There are two different endings
based on the subtle player choice, that sort of
thing. Now for the source code, the thing I'm
sufficiently happy with is how its coded to the
browser's JavaScript engine. The idea was to avoid
problems like performance problems during the high
level designs so that we don't need super clever
optimizations later, like two days before release,
I'll give two small examples of that. First,
in JavaScript garbage collector can unpredictably
pause the execution of your program and do its
thing to free memory. And on a 60 FPS monitor,
you have 16 and a half milliseconds to render
each frame, meaning that garbage collector can
drop frames easily, and make the game stutter.
And one workaround for that is to just allocate
everything you need ahead of time. So that garbage
collector has nothing to do. For example, in
the first contact game, there are all these
objects that are orbital platforms and cannons
and projectiles and of course, the invaders.
And every object is a very small state machine
with a small number of states. So let me show
it here. In the source code, a cannon can be
either ready to fire or it can be reloading.
What helps with garbage collector is that
all objects have an additional state,
which is called missing, which you
can see right here. And so when we
fire rocket, we do not allocate a new object
like new rocket, we instead pre allocate all
of the rockets at the start of the game seven
missing by default. And when we needed to fire,
we find the first one that's missing and use
that when the rocket hits, it reverts back to
the missing state. So we have zero allocations,
and garbage collector is very happy with us.
So here you can see, for example, like the
cannon, which has all these states. And when we,
at the start of the application, when we create
all of the possible like like cannons and rockets
and invaders, we we just allocate them here, there
is no allegation, there is no like new counter new
rocket anywhere in the code, apart from this
specific place at the beginning of the game.
Yeah, the second thing is also very small.
And it's related to the fact that all drawing
in this game is done on HTML, Canvas. And
Canvas has great performance. But when you
need to render possibly 1000s of objects in
every frame at 60 frames per second or more,
the rendering costs quickly end up. The trick is
very simple. Let's say we have the Space Invaders,
drawing one Invader is simple. We'll make a bunch
of lines of calls and then we'll go stroke feel
or what have you. You're all familiar with the
Canvas API. Now, what about drawing 1000 of these?
It turns out one way to optimize mass rendering is
to first make all of the line to calls for all the
invaders. Like here, you can see the render method
for the invader. And it has all these line tools
and close path. And when we actually invoke
this method here, we have a function to render
all of the invaders at once. So it first
invokes all the line tools and only then
it does stroke or feel or anything. This works
because the browser scanners implementation,
which is actually highperformance C++ code
works best if we give it a lot of stuff
to rasterize at once. So like all of the
invaders or all of the particles at once.
The anti pattern here would be a common stroke,
like every time for each line segment and this is
known to kill performance. So that's all for me.
Come participate in Gs 13k competition next year.
At number 11 We have shuttle deck by
Ariel Wexler. Hi, my name is Arielle,
and I'm the creator of shuttle deck. You
can find me on Twitter as Ari neon shark
I make all sorts of games simulations
and fun little procedural animations.
Okay, so let's dive right in
and take a look at shuttle deck.
At its core Federal Bank is an infinite runner
crossed with a deck builder game. So I thought
that would just be a funny combination of
genres. I haven't seen that done before.
So he around professors orange lab and we're
serving kind of as a space courier will be
traveling between planets avoiding obstacles on
the way. And we need to help Professor Zorn over
here on the right to deliver his package the Xeno
transponder. So let's go ahead and help them out.
So here we are traveling through space, we see
some minerals, we see some asteroids, and have
these cards down here, I can press on these cards,
and I will actually changed the lane that my
spaceship is in, that was a pretty easy run. For
me, I didn't have any obstacles that really were
in my way. Excellent. In between level, so I
just I just moved between two planets there.
Every time I reach a new planet, I'll encounter
some sort of strange character, in this case,
the street merchant, and he's offering me a
few cards that I can buy. Now in this case,
I don't actually have enough minerals
to buy the cars that he's offering.
So we're gonna have to go again, let's check
out one more stop here and see if we'll
actually be able to afford something,
just miss that. That's unfortunate.
We go. Okay, it's looking pretty
good. 16 usually goes a long way.
Alright, Kepler missile, no problem, go ahead
and grab one of those. But this will help me do
is if I have an asteroid in my way, I'll just be
able to shoot it, boom, and get it out of my way.
Perfect. So that's the core of the game. And now I
guess we can dive into a bit of how it all works.
And what I'm really excited to share with you
guys is the event emitter, I have my own custom
implementation of a very, very small event emitter
that I use in the game. So we'll we'll look at the
code in a moment. But let's just talk quickly
about why this is important to the game at all.
So you just saw shuttle deck. And the way that
it actually works is this, the game engine itself
is completely decoupled from all of these other
little components, they don't really know about
each other. So let's think for a moment about you
know, maybe how the main character shoots rockets.
So the way that works is if you have the,
you know, shoot a rocket card right here,
right, so we have that here, the player is going
to click this, and what's going to happen is
in little event is going to be emitted.
And I'll just kind of draw that is a little
loudspeaker, you know, some holding a loudspeaker
and it's shouting out. Now what's happening is
all these other systems in the game, you can think
of them as ears, they're essentially listening. So
that's, that's what an ear looks like, I guess.
So, you know, all these systems are listening.
And what they're listening for is events. In
this case, the event was, hey, I pressed the
shoot of a rocket card. So each one of these
systems is actually going to receive that message,
but only the relevant one should respond, I'd like
to take some time to look at the actual code that,
you know, fuels all this. So here we are in the
cards definition file. This has all the cards
in the game has their color, their name, much
cost, to use them or buy them a little code to
friend or them. It's a little glyph, that shows
up on the card in game. And finally there is the
actual code for handling what happens when you
use the card. None of the actual implementation
of what to do when you use the card lives in
here. It actually just outsources all of that
using that exact same strategy of just emitting
what should happen. And all the relevant systems
on the other end are kind of receiving what
what what to do with, with these emits. So
here we are looking at the Kepler missile, the
same thing we've been talking about throughout all
the examples. And all it does is says, hey, when
you use this card, just emit projectile type one,
it just says that out into the world. And the
you know, the world of the game needs to then
understand what to do with that. So let's go
ahead and look at who might receive that. So
here we are. I'm looking at the main game engine
that's actually listening for projectile offense.
And it's listening for the projectile type as
the only data parameter that comes into it.
So just like the projectile creation code we
just looked at here I am in the Audio Manager.
And we can see right here that I'm
listening to that exact same event,
and I receive the actual type. If the type is
type one, I play the sound for a missile. So
here you can actually see all the sounds for
the game. I'm just listening for all sorts of
other events that are going on, and I play the
correspondingly correct sound. I didn't have to
introduce anything intrusive at other parts
of the game. But it's all nicely localized
right here. So why am I bringing this up at all?
Well, mostly because I love using event emitters.
And I think they're a very necessary part of
making certain types of games. And if we look at,
you know, state of the art libraries, like event
emitter three, let's say for JavaScript, or node,
this thing is getting 15 million weekly
downloads, like, Oh, my goodness.
So this sounds like the right thing to use, right?
Yeah, well, there's only one problem with that,
if we go ahead and actually look at the minified
code for it, it's, it's kind of massive,
and it's a bit more feature rich than we probably
need. In fact, this is about, you know, three KB,
it could probably compress a bit more using few
of our tools. But still, this is way too much
code for what we actually need. So we're finally
getting to the punchline of what I'm so excited
to share with you. And here it is. It's a really,
really small version of an event emitter library
that compresses really nicely here, it says about
346 bytes. But actually, once this goes through
minifier and Uggla fire, this code will go down
to close to about 112 bytes. And I guess when
you run it through road roller, it'll probably be
even less than that in the grand scheme. So thanks
for tuning in and checking out shuttle deck. I
hope you enjoyed what I had to share about it.
At number 10, we have lost a snake in space by
Sun raising on behalf Maxine. Hello, I'm Maxime,
a web developer and game developer from France and
I developed my 10th js 13k game entry this year,
you can find me on Twitter here, or on YouTube or
on my blog. This year, I made a puzzle game where
you control a little snake that visits different
worlds, and needs to reproduce the patterns drawn
on the floor with his body to progress and
eventually reach the moon, where he will find
the final hardest puzzles of the game. In each
wild, you learn new mechanics like climbing walls,
using teleporters, wrapping, moving in 3d and
so on. And it becomes quite challenging when you
pass the first puzzles. You can play it on PC
and mobile right here. In regards to the code,
my favorite parts of the code is the graphics.
The first is regarding the snake. I spent many
days researching a way to represent a cute snake
in 3d, and finally found an elegant solution that
requires very little code. I use a big circle for
the head and many smaller circles for the body.
aligning all these circles and making them move
together gives a pretty good illusion of a snake
body with a real volume. Even if it's just a
bunch of flat circles rendered with HTML and
CSS. The game is rendered with a little CSS 3d
library that I developed before the competition.
It is called CSS 3d framework and you can find
it here. It allows us to easily draw and animate
3d shapes with very little code. Here is the J
S code for the snake. And here is the CSS code
for the snake as well. Next up I want to talk
about the code I use for the ground textures.
During the competition I met fence, he
creates gorgeous textures using SVGs.
Each of them is about half a kilobyte,
which is perfect for Gs 13 games,
where the entire game size is very limited. All
the textures present in my game were created by
Him. The grass, the sun, the moon, and even the
lava, or his CSV art can be found just right
here. Here are the textures I used in my game and
then minified SVG code. Here we have the grass.
Here we have the sand. Here we have the moon.
And here we have the lava. These techniques and
many others are detailed in the games making of
right over here. Thanks and see you next year.
At number nine, we have black
hole square by Quinton Klaus.
Hello, my name is Quinton Clauser. It's
the first time I submitted something for
Gs 13k. I've been following the competition
for as long as I can remember. But
this is the first year I submitted something. The
game is called Black Hole square. As you can see,
it's a little bit heavy focus on mobile
controls, actually you just step the tiles
they move so you have different kinds of tiles
that move in different directions. And goal of
the game is to put all the tiles into black
holes, little black holes, so you need to
clear the screen of all the white piles and then
you finish a level. So when I'm not participating
in the game jam, I keep text documents in
which I write game ideas. I have things
that come to mind are writable down in this text
document. And then when again, jump starts, I'll
quickly go over it and see if there are any ideas
I can use. Actually, this year's ID was from a
sketch, I already scribbled down in my notebooks.
So when the gym starts, I create a new document,
which will be like the design document for the
game. And which I put to do like little notes.
I don't actually do all these things. But just
if I have any ideas, I just put them in there.
And also put a copy in there. So the copy for
the game, like little sketches for the levels,
the graphics are made with Affinity Designer,
and I export them as SVG. And then I use a tool
called SVG, oh, you can install it with NPM
globally, and then you can compress the SVG s.
And then I did I am, I take out the parts. And I
and I use part two D to render the different parts
of the SVG. One of the most important files in the
code base is the entities print Jason. It contains
all the data from the game, like the order
in which the puzzles are recopy for the game,
and The puzzles themselves. So they
are just little arrays. This point,
I always have a fairly small notebook in my
pocket. So I can make little levels. When I'm
on the go. While I'm waiting for something, just
make little levels, make them on paper first.
And then afterwards, I put them in a one
of the most important files are where most
of the code this is the puzzle part. Yes, it
also contains the keys. So there's a comment,
which contains the keys, which all the digits
are in the arrays of levels, as you can see,
contains a lot of lot code, like mostly when I'm
working, there's always one file in the code base
that starts piling up code. In this project.
It's the puzzle that is truly a mess,
like No comments. And this thing also contains
my favorite part of the code, which is an event
listener for the wheel event, which actually makes
the swiping like the swiping controls makes them
work on a laptop. If you swipe on the trackpad,
like it works on all the laptops, I tried
to listening for the real event, you can make the
swiping work on desktop to on laptops, at least.
That's it. If you want to find out more
about my work, you can find me on the
internet on these URLs. If you have any
questions, I'd be happy to answer them.
Thank you for listening. And I hope to see
you on another edition of Gs 13k Thank you.
In spot eight, we have space huggers
by Frank force. Howdy. I'm Frank force,
also known as killed by pixel, a game
developer and generative artist in Austin,
Texas. Today I'm gonna share with you some
of the secrets by my GS 13k game space
huggers. It's a running gun roguelike hybrid with
procedurally generated fully destructible levels.
It has an explosion and fire propagation system
that creates all sorts of unpredictable chaos
and chain reactions while you're playing.
That's what I'm going to show you today.
First, let's take a look at
the game and see how it works.
You can get the full source code for my
game space huggers off the GitHub website.
I've already gone ahead and downloaded space
huggers and open it up in Visual Studio.
The first thing I'm going to do is
an app effects. I'm going to enable
debug fire. That's going to show us some
debug information when a fire event occurs.
For an explosion, it's going to show you two
circles and a radius and outer radius. The
air radius represents what is what is completely
destroyed and the outer radius is what's called
fire. When something is on fire, it will draw a
red circle to represent a fire event. is being
sent out to nearby objects to let them know
that they might also want to catch on fire.
This fire events are not set out
every frame, but only periodically for
optimization. Let's open up app objects. And
I'll show you how some of the fire stuff works.
You've got a couple of variables,
burn delay, that's how long it is
before something starts burning and a burn
time. That's how long something burns for.
Now, in the update function, it checks if it has
a burn time, that means it can catch on fire,
then it checks is the burn timer set, that means
it's burning. So if the burn time has elapsed,
that means it's, you know, a
lot of it's pretty burnt out,
which means it tries to tries to die. If
there's a fire meter, you have to turn that off.
There's also a small chance to spread the fire.
And this is what causes the really cool chain
reactions to happen. You don't want this to
happen every frame because it's kind of a slow
system to go through each every each and every
object and check its radius to see if it's close
enough to catch on fire. Of course you can, you
can do things to speed that up. But it's always
going to be a bit slow. So you don't want
to do that kind of thing every single frame.
And you don't need to, it's good to have a
little bit of randomness and something like this.
It also checks the bird delay timer.
If the bird delay timer is elapsed,
then it starts burning. There's other
stuff in here called a burn color percent,
which kind of alerts the burn timer to make
things darker as they get burnt. And if you want
to burn something directly, we just call this burn
function. And that sets up the different stuff to
create burn system it creates a fire emitter and
attaches that as a child sets the burn timer.
And there's also a way to extinguish fires. For
example, by just rolling you'll put out a fire
where you can also be near a water barrel. When
you explode a water barrel sort of burning,
it actually puts out everything nearby and just
extinguishes things in a radius and that sets
distinguish timer, it unsets the fire effect then
timers and set things back to normal basically.
I hope that gives you a good idea about how
the fire system and my game works and how you
might implement something similar in your own
game. I'm gonna give you a quick demonstration
to end things out here. I like to tell you to
follow me on Twitter also made the game engine
for this game open source. You can get that on
my GitHub, it's called Little J S. Next year,
I'll be using a little J S to make a new
game for j s 15k. And I hope that you do too.
So thanks for watching, take care
of yourselves and have a great day.
In seven space, we have the maze of space goblins
by Yanni new cannon. The Moses face goblins is a
puzzle game that combines Sokoban like gameplay
mechanics with match through the graphics are
extremely retro and work very well for the type of
game that it is the level of care around the intro
and the option to have the sound on or off was
very much appreciated by the judges. You can
play the game by collecting stars to progress
to the next level and by matching three or more
space goblins of the same color to destroy them
as it make space for you to move. The game has
made use the arrow keys to move backspace to undo
a move or to restart and enter to pause the game.
Yanni tested this game on Firefox and various
chromium based browsers such as opera and edge.
He also tested it on Linux and Windows as to make
sure the user had the best possible experience no
matter what browser they were using. The bitmap
font was one of my favorite fonts that I've seen
as competition. This game had also an interesting
approach to creating the levels as you can see
here with the data tag, and was one of the few
projects which use TypeScript to create the game.
As you can see by the TSX files, Judge
Jupiter Hadleys said he loved the graphics.
They were really simple, but a fun game. He
loved the challenges in it. Ralph Mertens,
the name definitely got my attention funny intro
to the game does a good job of getting you engaged
and he thinks that the puzzles were excellent
and quite challenging. They had him playing
for a while great simple puzzle game that's
deceptively hard with retro visuals and sound.
In sixth place, we have Packer bunches by Mattea
fu to natty Hi, I'm Mattea game developer some
time for a B sometimes for work, always for
passion, because I really really love games
and game design. I'm I'm very fond of Gs 13k
games, because of all the creativity can push
with all the great ideas coming out every year.
And so I always try to participate whenever I can.
So now let's jump to my 2021 entry Bokoblin. Just
like Adventures is a colorful tiling puzzle game
in which you have to rescue space creatures by
packing them. It is playable from both desktop
and mobile. And as for controls, you just
use clicks of ducks. I am really proud of
this game. And not only because I think it came
out to be very nice, but also mainly because I
had a great time making it. In fact, my personal
goal and approach this year was to fully enjoy the
creative experience behind the development of
every single part of the game. Let me explain.
For example, to create a music I didn't
just sit there trying to compose something.
Instead, I met with a musician friend of mine,
and we spent the whole afternoon listening to
puzzle game music from all Nintendo games
for inspiration. We had snacks and drinks,
sharing ideas in front of the piano.
And in the end, we came up with these
personal Vish jets each chord
progression for puck adventures.
So you see like this, whatever the result, I had
a great time exploring new things with a friend.
Same thing goes for the logo and the mascot
created doing some brainstorms with my girlfriend,
in which we had fun accentuating shapes and trying
different goofy designs with paint for the logo
and pen and paper for the little character. As for
the gameplay, since the theme this year was based,
I get lost for days exploring been packing
problems in space management algorithms.
To get some inspiration, I eagerly explode from
feng shui principles to scientific papers on
automated furniture placement. And so I learned
many things like furniture, usability rankings,
relationships between objects,
human navigation, space, and so on.
Again, as you can see, I stuck with a more
simple polynomial shapes packing game with
some Yahwistic brute force for level generation.
But it has really been an adventure, believe me.
So maybe now you're curious about backbenches
code about how it can fit into 10 kilobytes.
And you want to check it on GitHub. Well,
just don't do it. Like a bunch of code is bad,
messy, full of mistakes and unused or redundant
workaround ish copy paste the things not really.
I couldn't make the code presentable for the
deadline. So we stayed you should check this one.
This is a basic Gs 15 kg games template
which I made post competition which is
some water we organized cleaner version,
or what they use for puck adventures.
It includes some features that I personally
see at the moment and standards in this
field of making games interesting kilobyte
that I like to reuse myself in the future.
Many of these solutions are not my own, and
every specific owner is credited with links.
For example, he has the document
setup, we have the middle attack to
be sure emojis are shown. And we have the cool
cheap trick here to send an emoji is fav icon,
which will also be the game icon mobile
if you use the Add to Home page feature.
Then we have Canvas centering and resizing handle
with the wrapping. very readable and very solid.
As for the audio part, my tools of choice here are
Z FX and the GFX m by Frank force and Keith Clark,
which you may already know and which I
highly suggest you to go and check out.
And so like this, we have a clickable
centered fit canvas with emojis audio
icon and mobile compatibility. I'd say it's
a great starting point to create a game.
But the thing that made it really possible
to fit backbenches into 13 kilobytes,
and that practically remove the sides
concentrate is the build process. This year,
a new JavaScript compression tool came out
making everyone's life easier. And talking about
words roller by Kenson goon go check it out.
So the suggested bid process here is first use
Google Closure Compiler to recompile the code
then third sir to crush it. And finally once
roller to compress it This will extremely
reduce the size of your scripts. So you can
now put them inside your already minified.
HTML and zip them at maximum compression. And here
we have one last three couples leaves using AECT.
We can even optimize this final step
more reducing the size by semester bytes.
My template also features a batch bill to
automate all of this, which I deliberately
took from Frank for centuries based hargus and
modified for my needs. You can find it included
in the bill folder, or commented along with
a link to the original one. Thank you, Frank.
So as you can see, even when talking about
code, I've had a great time keeping up to date
with the GS 13k games word, discovering
and playing with all these great tools.
And Willie, Willie, enjoy making puppet bunches.
Alright, thanks for listening thanks to the Free
Code Camp staff for the opportunity of being here.
Thanks to MJ for keeping the competition
up every year. And thanks to the ozone
community for sharing old ideas, tips
and projects. Thank you guys. So yeah.
In fifth place, we have Welcome to Space
by Matthew tiamont. In this game, we play
hero looking to save this space station
from evil but kinda cute looking aliens.
These wicked aliens are armed to the teeth but
so are you. In this game, you can use your vast
arsenal to conquer the six different alien types
and make your way to the Ultimate Alien boss.
The pixel art was adorable for this game, and
the variety given to the weapons and evil alien
characteristics was very impressive. I was most
intrigued about the deciding junk factors that
were there for the aliens so had a quick look at
the code and must applaud how neat I found it.
Here the different types of enemy types in the
game. We have the aggro enemy the running gun, the
idiot, the pacifists and the Sentinel each have
their own color scheme for the skin, horns, eyes
and body. You will also see the different ways
the enemies act thanks to that enemy personas. To
remove your alien in this game you can use the
keyboard or you can use controller support such
as a controller D pad or joysticks. On the
keyboard, you move with either left and right
A and D and jump with either up or the W key shift
or control as well as shoot with the spacebar.
Make sure to give it a go
in the description below.
In fourth place, we have Galaxy rider by job
burns, raising on behalf of Jeremy burns. Hi,
I'm Jeremy burns, or John Burns, and you
can find me online at javelins dotnet,
I bought Galaxy rider for the GS 13k games
jam in 2021. This is a game where the goals
and mechanisms are simple and the difficulty comes
from learning to master the mechanics themselves.
I've always liked games where progression comes
from a real improvement of the players skill.
And this game sticks to the philosophy quite
strongly. The goal is simply to collect all the
floating dots and then get the skater to the exit
as fast as possible. The initial challenge is just
to complete the levels at all. And replayability
comes from the timer. I was inspired to make this
game because I think the physical mechanics of
riding a pool or a bowl on a skateboard are quite
interesting and fun. And I wanted to capture some
of that in a 2d platformer. I thought about doing
something like this in 3d. But I just couldn't
imagine pulling off a novel 3d movement mechanic
in 3d in the confines of the jam. My favorite
part of the code is probably the animation editor.
It's quite ugly code, but it does exactly what was
required of it and nothing more, which is nice in
its own kind of way. The way that animation editor
works is by simply rendering some Jason specified
lines and circles to a large canvas and giving
me a text field in which I can input that Jason.
It also provides a timeline which I could scrub
to see how animation frames could blend together,
and some basic mouse handles for position editing.
I built a character sprites and all the animations
using this tool. The level editor was another
minimalist tool I bought for the game. Though
it was a bit more sophisticated. It allowed me to
place positive and negative shapes into the world,
which when combined together, found all the
various geometry you find in the game. Overall,
I think the game came together quite well and
I'm happy that other people seem to enjoy it too.
In third place, we have Adventures
of Captain Calista by Cody Everson.
Hello, my name is Cody person. I am a software
engineer in San Francisco, California.
And today I'd like to talk about my GS 13k entry.
The Adventures of Captain Callisto Callisto is a
3d action platform been set in outer space. This
is my third time entering the GS 13k competition.
My first entry was J S 13k battlegrounds in
2018, a battle royale first person shooter.
My second entry was mini Punk in 2020, cyberpunk
third person action game. In those entries,
my goal was to make an impressive technical demo.
The entries did well graphically, but they weren't
considered fun. I also noticed that a significant
portion of the GS 13k audience does not really
enjoy first person or third person games. So my
goals for this year were to make something fun,
make something relatively easy, at least for
the first few levels and to make something
with a more global appeal. The most direct
inspiration for Callisto is probably Captain
Toad, Treasure Tracker, and Nintendo action
platform game. From a technology perspective,
the game rendering uses web GL to I extended my
previous entries to support instance rendering
of cubes and spheres. That means that it's pretty
fast and cheap and low code to draw a sphere or
a cube on the screen. All the models are simple
combinations of spheres and cubes. As an example,
let's talk about the main hero character, we
can strip everything away, and then add the
components of visor, the rest of the helmet,
the body, but jetpack arm, another arm,
leg and another leg. And that's how the rendering
works. We can then rotate those spheres to create
the animation effects. You see the spheres all
over the place, the dust clouds and the coins.
They're just stretched. Here's here's how that
looks in the code. You can see how we generate the
sphere, then translate it or move it, then scale
it or stretch it. And then in some cases, rotate
it to create those animation effects. And that is
the foundation of how all of the rendering works
in the entire game. Okay, that was a quick tour
of my entry The Adventures of Captain Cousteau.
Thank you so much for watching, and thank you to
the Free Code Camp team for putting this together.
In second place, we have beat rocks by cause this
game allows you to unleash your inner dancer. The
aim is to unlock new instruments of destruction
and make sure to play them on the beat. Reading on
behalf of cars cars said I think this is my third
or fourth attempt at making an asteroid game.
One attempt failed because I tried too
hard at making an entity component system.
Another because I didn't come up with any asset
pipeline. So I promised that I'll try the next
one in 3d with wireframe rendering, so that
I can have some nice animations for rotating
objects while keeping the retro it's all lines of
visuals. The idea was in my mind for a long time,
but I wasn't eager to start until fat fish told
me that Gs 13 is starting and space is the theme.
I couldn't pass over it. I wasn't originally
planning to make this a rhythm game. The idea
randomly came up later and it seemed to work.
I was playing a lot of Tetris effects earlier
this year, so I tried toying with the idea of
sound effects contributing to the music play
test revealed that it is confusing that when the
plays and ability the effect triggers immediately,
but the sound only plays on the next beat. This
led to the conclusion why not require the player
to use skills on the beat. I compose the music on
a Nintendo Switch then moved over to sandbox. I'm
interested in since by have almost zero experience
with composing it's my longest song so far. Some
tech facts for you about this game is that he also
used sandbox for sound effects. The sounds were
done as other instruments in the same track so
that he could test how everything sounds together.
Since soundbox, saves the song as Jason he was
able to extract and trim the soundtracks in the
game code to separate audio buffers. And in
regards to the graphics he use our ETL rgl
gives a convenient type interface of a raw Web
GL deals away with all the boilerplate. Later,
he's written the rendering and roll Web GL to save
space. This was planned for the beginning as he
knew our AGI would be too big. He then modeled
some 3d objects in SketchUp, save to OBJ and
provided a simple JSON representation. He also use
snippets from Patricio Gonzalez vivos just for the
shader noise texture, which made the background a
little more interesting. In regards to the build
and compression parser was used for the build
pipeline. He likes parser because it has zero
modules, TypeScript and minification by Tasa was
zero setup. He'd never used parcel in production,
but he used it for all the toy projects and
prototypes. Tasa doesn't touch shaders, so he
minified them manually using GLSL X. And finally,
let's reveal the number one winner of the GS 13k
Ryan says I've always been inspired by the
fantasy console community and all the fantastic
that uses similar constraints via a simple drawing
API and frame buffer I've refined over the years
that's heavily inspired by fantasy consoles. In my
free time, I've been working on cleaning up retro
buffer for a more official release. So other
jammas might more easily make a game with it.
I'd love to see that. A huge thank you to Andrei
and everyone else involved with managing Gs 13k